hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll and
you know economics is always tough for
me to cover here on the podcast I love
it I think it's fascinating it's also
kind of intimidating and difficult I
don't think that there's any other field
which is simultaneously as
quantitatively rigorous and
deeply involved with the complexities of
social life as economics is it's a story
of theorems and results but also one
that is supposed to apply to the real
world and as we all know economic theory
has both successes and kind of dramatic
failures happily today's guest Samuel
Bowles is super easy to talk to I don't
do that much talking in this particular
podcast because Sam is so good at
explaining what he's thinking about and
it's very very interesting stuff about
how to think about the role of human
beings within economic systems but also
going backwards what thinking
economically can teach us about human
beings how human beings actually behave
not just the simple toy models of very
oversimplified economic models now Sam
has been a long time collaborator of
previous mindscape guest herb gentis
sadly herb passed away back in January
at the age of 82 but he and Sam have
been working together since their
graduate school years in the 1960s it's
a fascinating story I I have the
impression that if Sam were here to tell
you his biography it would last many
many hours and be super fascinating he's
LED quite a colorful life but one part
of that story is that Sam and Herb
gyntis were asked by Martin Luther King
to help him study up on economics to ask
a bunch of questions about economics and
inequality in 1968 just before the Poor
People's March just before Martin Luther
King was assassinated
and apparently The Story Goes that the
two of them Sam and Herb were kind of
chagrined that their expert training in
economics I think they were still grad
students at the time was completely
inadequate to answer these questions
about inequality so they really started
thinking deeply about these questions
that were being ignored by mainstream
economics and they both taught at
Harvard for a little while before being
stolen away by UMass Amherst who hired a
group of people there was this you know
famous radical group of economists that
UMass Amherst hired and they worked
together for a long time uh herb and Sam
wrote a quite well-known book called
schooling in capitalist America about
how the educational system interacts
with and serves our capitalist system of
economics and certainly both of them Sam
included are identified as members of
the left wing of economic side but as
you will see as you will hear anyway in
the podcast Sam is scrupulously fair
when he describes the contributions and
the shortcomings of different aspects of
Economics he's very very quick to give
credit to the free market to Adam Smith
even to sort of 20th century neoliberal
economics but he thinks that we can do
better he thinks we can go further and
we'll talk about that but also this
particular conversation is not very
political to be honest we're really
thinking about how to analyze systems
economically what we learn about human
beings by doing experiments that are
informed by economics by thinking about
Game Theory and interactions why are
human beings as cooperative and
altruistic as they sometimes are in fact
a much more recent book maybe the last
book that Sam and Herb wrote together is
called a Cooperative species human
reciprocity and its Evolution and
there's a very short motto for the
lesson of this book that you will have
to listen to the podcast to hear about
but you know we human beings we're
complicated sometimes we're kind of
selfish self-interested as Adam Smith
assumed for the purposes of his models
by the way as Sam points out Adam Smith
didn't think we were always perfectly
self-interested just that's a good
starting point for the model sometimes
though human beings are kind of nice to
each other sometimes how do you fit that
into the model what does that have to
say how can that help us how can we use
these insights to tackle some of the
global large-scale problems we have
today all that and more in this episode
so let's go
foreign
[Music]
balls welcome to the mindscape podcast
great to be here
so I'm going to start off
from my perspective a little bit you'll
forgive me but there's at least a cliche
or a stereotype or a story that
economists kind of love physics right
there's even physics Envy is that number
one is that true and number two does it
come from somewhere respectable
I think we used to love physics and we
loved physics in the 30s and 40s of the
last century
because some Economist Paul Simonson
notably borrowed a lot of ideas from
physics and used them to formalize ideas
of economic equilibrium and some of the
basic ideas which hadn't been
mathematized yet
I was fortunate to be in grad school in
the early 60s and so I was part of the
wave that mathematized the standard
canon in economics and of course it was
very exciting and we got to do things
that were mathematically pretty simple
but seemed powerful and seemed like a
real Advance over the more Narrative
Approach to economics which it held sway
prior to then
when I say used to I would I say that
because there's another analogy in the
physical sciences which is to biology
and it's interesting that uh Alfred
Marshall founder of the neoclassical
School of Economics uh which I would say
is has recently been uh deposed as the
convention in economics Alfred Marshall
used biological analogies he wanted to
think about growth and Decay and copying
and so on
um and uh that view has also now become
quite prominent in in economics now we
know how to do constrained optimization
we start to think about well how do
systems move as a whole and
we want to get away from just thinking
about the stationarity of something in
equilibrium but what does it do when
it's not an equilibrium or maybe if
there is not an equilibrium to which the
system can be attracted so I think uh we
were really borrowing analogies from
lots of fields
um it's also True by the way that other
fields have borrowed analogies from
economics so it's probably a well-known
uh uh to most scientists that Darwin got
his idea of natural selection from
Thomas Malthus The Economist and in fact
he said I'm just applying malthus's
ideas to the in all species so there's
been a lot of fruitful interplay
uh but I think none of the physical
science analogies really work perfectly
in economics and the real problem
is that people when they act are trying
to accomplish something they've got an
objective their their intentionality
really matters and very often we find
ourselves running up against the
intentionality of somebody else so we
have these interactions which uh are you
can model them as if they were particles
or as if they were alleles uh in uh in a
biological setting but there's an
intentionality part of the story that
isn't well captured by non-thinking
particles or
genes that are only said to as if
optimized but they're not really
thinking about optimizing and trying to
do so so the subjectivity of human
beings are intentionality bring
something new and it's only in the last
30 years that we've begun to see just
how different that is and so we've been
moving away from some of the more
physical analogies making economics more
of a social science if not the social
science that it was 30 40 years ago the
role of intentionality is very important
I wouldn't have put it that way but I
get where you're coming from you know I
recently had David krakauer on my
podcast and we disagreed a little bit on
the definition of complexity because he
put I guess what he would call teleonomy
front and center he thinks of complex
systems as systems which have goals
right which have interests which I guess
is the same as what you're saying about
intentions whereas physicists maybe
think about systems that are so
intrinsically simple that they just bump
into each other they don't have goals
when they go about it yes uh Murray
Goldman uh a founder of the Santa Fe
Institute where we're having this
interview today uh said think how hard
physics would be if particles could
think and yes that's right and uh so I
think the the reason why in economics
we've had this big boom in Game Theory
uh is because game theory is the
basically the applied math of uh
intentional interactions in which each
party recognizes that what they get in a
pay in a uh in an interaction will
depend on what the other does and the
other person also knows that so this to
summarize a strategic interaction is
mutual interdependence recognized by
both parties and I think that's like
Society uh I mean there was a great
dissertation by a great Economist Irving
Fisher uh and he included his
dissertation a hydraulic model of the
economy yeah and that was obviously a
physical model and gravity was doing the
work of optimization there so that the
water in the various parts of the model
unless it was impeded the water found a
similar level and so on now there are
all kinds of models like that in
economics in which the metaphor really
is transportation things moving from
here to there
but in in recent years some economists
myself included have been more attracted
to the idea that
economic interactions are more like a
conversation so we should really be
thinking about Linguistics that is I'm
having a conversation with you and in
saying what I'm saying now I'm
anticipating your response and very
often I'm having a conversation with
somebody with some intention that I
would like this person you know to agree
to go to see a film with me or to agree
to work on a paper and so on but I'm
anticipating what that person's
intention is to and of course in Endless
regress so uh I think as we move forward
in economics metaphors like uh language
rather than transportation
and metaphors coming not from biology or
from physics but actually from society
itself from the way that we
intentionally interact we'll come to the
fore but it's really raising hell with a
standard theory in economics because
once you recognize that people are not
just interacting with nature like
Robinson Crusoe we have it's actually a
different story and so economics is
being fundamentally Rewritten and it has
been so over the last 30 years well
that's very very interesting but for
those of us including myself who are not
uh surrounded by economics all the time
let's remind us what is being replaced
right I mean there is this tradition
going back to Adam Smith I guess of uh
thinking about Collective behavior and
individuals do what they want for their
own sakes and that comes up with
something good for society yes that's
right but let me go back to Robinson
Crusoe in an economics textbook you
don't lose anything if you represent
most of the models as a single
individual interacting with nature
Robinson Crusoe on his Island before
Friday the enslaved person showed up uh
and the reason for that is the way we
represent and choice we have an
individual and he or she is facing a set
of prices so there's a vector of prices
and that's given and then the person
decides what they're going to they'll
buy or sell they've got some Goods or
some capacities to produce and they're
looking at that vector and they're
optimizing against that surface now
that's no different from Robinson Crusoe
and his Island the surface is Robinson
cruso's Island and it's remarkable how
many many results in the standard
Paradigm of say three uh decades ago can
be represented as if it's just one
person operating on an island now okay
now of course uh that was pretty easy to
mathematize because it was basically
just constrained optimization and when I
began teaching Advanced microeconomic
Theory at Harvard all I was just
teaching constrained optimization it was
lots of different clothes on different
uh you know
application locations now there were
some very powerful results of that and
it was really there's some quite
remarkable ones the most remarkable
probably is Adam Smith's invisible hand
uh everyone knows that Adam Smith said
that society would be led as if by an
invisible hand to outcomes which
everyone would appreciate as a good
outcome even though people might be
completely self-interested and have no
interest in the uh in the well-being of
others now that is a radical thought
yeah and uh it's it's a very surprising
one uh it's very difficult to teach that
to undergrads they think it doesn't make
much sense uh and that's why we think of
Adam Smith as a great thinker now a few
provisos Adam Smith didn't think for one
second that people were entirely selfish
he was simply saying like many political
philosophers did let's think of a
constitution let's think of a way of
organizing our society which would work
even if everyone is basically a jerk
exactly so jerk proof constitutions is
what classical economics was all about
uh now uh now of course that view the
invisible hand has now been applied to
public policy in a number of areas uh in
some cases for the better in some cases
for the worse there are some areas in
which it works very well and there's
some areas in which it doesn't and I
think one of the main tasks of policy
making over the last couple of centuries
has been trying to figure out which
areas may be buying and selling shirts
uh is an area in which it works pretty
well uh in some other areas like hiring
and firing uh employees and labor or the
use of land or perhaps how we divide
devise our money and monetary
instruments there are many areas in
which we know it doesn't work very well
now uh so but that's not the main
problem with the theory uh the fact that
the invisible hand turned out to have a
rather limited realm of application was
of course that's just how science
progresses we figured out through
actually mathematics analysis partly the
work is Kenneth Arrow another founder of
the Santa Fe Institute that the domain
over which the assumptions of the
Invisible Hand would work was really
quite restricted but that wasn't the
problem I don't think economists were
ideologically wedded to the idea of the
Invisible Hand many people were
conservative people liked it but
economists for the most part it was
something that we thought about we
thought it was a remarkable hypothesis
and we explored its application I think
the problem is that there were some
results of that theory that we just
didn't observe in the world that is it
had a it had a prediction problem
now the most obvious prediction problem
was about supply and demand I sometimes
ask people uh in in a public lecture I
say with your arms please show me one
thing you've learned in the economics
course that you've taken and inevitably
a good number of people cross their arms
and say supply and demand and I say yes
that's it that's what you learn and of
course what you also learned is the
answer is where the lines cross and
that's where Supply equals demand now
this is a powerful Theory and as I said
it might work for shirts but it
certainly doesn't work for labor that is
for people searching to find work and
people searching to find employees
because we know we typically have a
substantial fraction of the population
that is unable to find work it differs
from country to country but it's always
there now the the the a major uh change
in economic thinking took place during
the Great Depression
because obviously when you have a
quarter of the labor force unemployed
that's too big a problem to just ignore
and say well it's due to frictions or
it'll fix itself or whatever and that's
when we had a big innovation John
Maynard Keynes came along and said no
actually that model doesn't work for the
labor market we have to have a different
theory for that now Kane just didn't
explain exactly why it didn't work he
observed that it didn't work and he
proposed an alternative
um uh by the way Paul Samuelson also
said the same thing in his in his uh
introductory textbook written right
after the Great Depression he taught
about supply and demand rather briefly
uh and he basically said don't try this
on the labor market that you're going to
have to have a different theory for that
now it took a long time to figure out
what was wrong with the standard Theory
but what it comes down to is that
how do you get the supply and demand
model to work is that you have to assume
something about how we transact our
business and
um what seems like a really small Point
turns out to be of Mammoth importance
and it's this if we're transacting
something like say a shirt uh and I
agree to pay thirty dollars for the
shirt that you have and you give me a
box which is said to have a shirt in it
and I get home and there's no shirt or
it's not the shirt that you said I can
get my money back uh and probably pretty
costlessly
um so that's what's called a complete
contract a complete contract means that
everything that you and I care about in
this transaction is actually going to be
taken care of by the law and it's not
exactly you call 9-1-1 but you do get
redress if the contract isn't met now as
again that works for shirts uh and it
works for a whole lot of other things
but now think of what it doesn't work
for
if you were to employ me to uh work on
some project let's say uh and uh you
offered me an hourly wage or a salary uh
what you would have done is you didn't
purchase my work as a researcher you
purchased my time yeah so you you're
essentially renting me but you're not
renting my talent you're not renting my
ideas you're just renting my willingness
to come to your research institute and
sit there at the computer and uh appear
to work now the problem is to get your
project done you need me to get the work
done yeah and so so that uh to see why
that's an a an incomplete contract your
promise to me to pay my salary that's a
complete contract uh that's enforceable
my agreement to show up at your place
that's also enforceable my agreement to
work is not enforceable now this is
where the Game Theory comes in because
if if I'm at your interest suit and it
turns out after a couple of months you
notice that I haven't been uh getting
any work done and you find out that I've
probably been just uh communicating with
my friends there's really nothing you
can do about it well there's one thing
you can do about it you can terminate my
contract and that's about all you can do
in a liberal Society I mean
philosophically liberal Society you
can't beat me you can't imprison me but
you can say okay that's it Sam uh you're
out of here now that's roughly the way
it works that's I mean that's part of
the motivation of uh of an employee now
in order for that to work
you know as my employer that you should
have offered me a wage or a salary
Superior to what I would get if I'd been
fired otherwise I wouldn't care I I you
know you'd come in and say Sam you're
out of here and I'd say make my day I'll
go across the street to the research
institute over there and that would be
the case if Supply equals demand because
if Supply equals demand it means there
is there are there are there's nobody
who wants work who doesn't get it uh
that means you can cross the street well
now of course people finally figured out
that that's why the supply and demand
model didn't work Keynes knew that it
didn't work but it took until the 70s or
80s for a whole bunch of writers to
figure out oh
the employers are actually paying more
than the minimum because they want to
get the person to work uh now that fact
that they're paying more than the
minimum uh is tantamount is saying that
there have to be other people out there
just like me who could have my job uh
you could replace me with that person uh
they're just like me but they don't have
the job now that opens up a lot of new
things we could think about uh I'll come
in a minute to have the same problem
applies in a credit market and so on
okay let's continue with employment
so you're now paying me a lot more than
I could get somewhere else
and what that means is I'm afraid of
losing my job that also means that you
can essentially tell me what to do for
example work hard Sam uh you can tell me
what to do with the expectation that
I'll do that thing uh which I wouldn't
have done otherwise and perhaps which I
wouldn't even want to do
now
the a situation in which one person can
can threaten someone with a sanction
some cost to get them to act in a way
which is advantageous to them uh when
the reversibility isn't true that I
couldn't threaten you yeah uh I mean
that that's pretty close to what we mean
by when that a has power over B so all
of a sudden a whole bunch of
non-economic things get uh front and
center in economics like the exercise of
Power by private actors and another
thing comes in which economists have
long tried to rule out let the
sociologists deal with the question of
social norms we don't really care about
social norms I don't care about what you
think or what you value but obviously
you do care about my social Norm because
you can't watch me all the time and you
know that threatening to fire me isn't
going to do the whole job so you kind of
hope that I share your love of science
uh or maybe I just share an obligation
to work hard because I said I would so
you start to care about sociological and
value characteristics of um of me now so
what that means is that economics which
had been really pretty intolerant of
insights from other disciplines now it
really needs to go to the political
science uh um people and say well okay
this power that's being exerted what do
you know about that and maybe the
sociologist or anthropologists can help
us out on why do some social norms
emerge and survive and so on so this the
idea of the contracts being incomplete
which it seems like a small legal
distinction right uh has actually really
shaken the whole house and uh and it
leads in a different direction from the
old Theory well it's very frequent in
math and physics that when you take a
theorem you've proven and then slightly
violate one of the assumptions you get
completely different results yes in fact
that's in the 70s and 80s when I started
working on this
um I knew that I was going to get
radically different results uh and so I
changed as little as possible uh so I I
adopted all of the standard assumptions
a perfectly competitive economy no
monopolies no nothing fancy just the
fact that there's something that one
party to an exchange wants to get but
they can't secure by means of a contract
uh and then the whole house comes
crumbling down uh and it was kind of fun
well and just going back because I am a
physicist to uh how physicists would
think about this it's not just that
Elementary particles don't think but the
economic actors you're pointing out they
have goals and intentions they also have
a theory of what the other economic
actors have in mind and their goals of
intentions and they also have this
ability of sort of counter factual
reasoning if I were to do this here's
how I would be punished and everything
and so even if we treated human beings
as kind a perfectly modelable those
models are going to be way more complex
than any physics theory you would have
to deal with yes and I think most people
myself included some years ago didn't
really appreciate just how hard those
models get and
um I think that my students my Advanced
students after a semester of working
with me they really wish they could go
back to Robinson Crusoe because at least
we know how to do the math with that
it's a simple question but I mean
suppose you have a interaction like this
you and I are going to interact I don't
know you I've never met you and we're
going to interact in some way that we're
going to produce something jointly and
then we're going to share the benefits
maybe it's a partnership or maybe we're
a couple sharing a household or whatever
we're some kind of partnership now
um uh my attitude towards you is that if
I think you're a pretty good guy well
then I'm willing to work hard and I
don't mind the benefits being shared
with with you
but only if you're going to reciprocate
that so now imagine I started off
thinking that you were a pretty good guy
and so I start off and I work pretty
hard well then you pick up from that
that I'm a pretty good guy and that
reinforces your view and off we go and
we have a very productive partnership
but notice also it could have gone the
other way uh if we come to work the
first day and neither of us had done
much of the project and uh you don't
have to think too hard about this it
could have gone there are very very many
equilibria of this problem uh in which
uh we don't really know how it's going
to happen and so I mean I've found for
example just doing the math is hard just
with two people yeah uh and sometimes
you turn to simulations and uh so the
students learning this they understand
that look uh we're talking about a view
of society in which it's fundamentally
more complicated than economics has
realized in the past and that's great
because it really is fundamentally more
complicated but it has some implications
for example
um economists myself included really
love to prove theorems but I think we're
going to be the last discipline that
really relies on theorems because we use
theorems because we we constructed an
artificial World in which uh
relationships were simply enough that
theorems could apply uh now once you get
outside of that world uh I mean there
are a few things you can say some pretty
clear propositions that are true
but for many many important problems
when you do the math you you can do the
math it's not that the math is hard it's
that you don't understand analytically
what it means you don't get intuitions
by this massive expression it may go on
for a page or two and therefore you have
to start experiments experimenting with
discovering there's some surface that
you're exploring you want to know what
it looks like and you use agent-based
models or other kinds of simulation
methods so it's changing a lot and but I
think I hope it's also having the effect
of making economists a bit more modest
about what science can do yeah that is
we uh we really are faced with deep
uncertainties and deep inadequacies of
our understanding and we shouldn't be
teaching students that you know we've
got this tool for understanding Society
we have a a box of tools that help in
some cases in some cases really quite
amazingly and in other cases are quite
powerless to give us the kind of
analysis that we really would need the
other thing I wanted to get on the table
about the old school way of doing it is
there is a back and forth between
description and prescription right I
mean you've talked about how in the
neoliberal way of thinking about things
that comes along with uh I don't know
whether it's Customs or morals or
whatever but there's and you know an
idea of procedural fairness an idea of
freedom to do things Etc
number one is that true am I
exaggerating and number two do you
therefore see it changing
no you're absolutely right about what's
called the neoliberal economic Paradigm
it's not primarily an academic Paradigm
but it's a it's a it's a it's a policy
Paradigm a way of looking at the world
and this is very interesting I think
that to your to your readers
um or listeners
um uh there's a one of the reasons why
this this uh conservative political
movement was so successful was that it
integrated very powerful moral
intuitions about Liberty
self-determination and so on a set of
ethical principles with a model of the
economy in which uh if you left people
to themselves and gave them the Liberty
the economy would work out pretty okay
yeah and um so that was I mean I I have
to also give the uh what are called the
neoliberal uh school credit because I
mean very often people say why were they
so successful and uh on the left you'll
hear people say well add all these think
tanks and they had all this money and so
on and I don't think that's the case at
all I mean yes they did have a lot of
money but of left of center
um Scholars intellectuals have a lot of
universities which also support them
I think they did some very good
economics and they relied on really
powerful economic arguments starting
with future kayak and coming on to some
of the more modern people uh who really
fundamentally posed a set of arguments
about why some favored left Alternatives
wouldn't work very well and why markets
worked if not optimally probably better
than the Alternatives and so in other
words there were some real economic
theory advances I mentioned Hayek
because his central idea
which is that information is local and
limited uh is very important to
understanding why some favorite leftist
ideas like Central economic planning
wouldn't work very well because the
planner could never know enough uh but
interestingly Hayek's ideas about
information are also the key idea behind
why contracts are incomplete the reason
why the contract between you and me is
incomplete is because you can't know
what I'm doing all the time and even if
you did your observation that you don't
think I was working hard enough would
not be admissible in a court of law as a
way of recovering wages because it would
be your word against mine no no I was
really working hard and so I think the I
mean it's so ironic that is Hayek who
wrote about information to show why
central planning wouldn't work also
initiated this new wave of economic
theory of which I am a part uh which
takes information as being a key problem
in economics and we have gone on to show
that an economic theory which
recognizing Hayek's which recognizes
Hayek's insights about information is
really very very different from the
economic theory favored by the
neoliberal school because it shows for
example that Supply doesn't equal demand
in many cases and if Supply doesn't
equal demand then the Invisible Hand
argument of Adam Smith is wrong then we
have as I said earlier the uncomfortable
fact of the private exercise of power
sometimes immense powers of employers
over employees and so on so it's higher
Hayek and information economics I've
opened up a whole new Arena but yes
indeed that was what the neoliberals
pushed uh it was a coherent set of
economic theories and moral principles
and I think it's it's we can conclude
from that that anything which is going
to replace
the neoliberal Paradigm as a policy
Paradigm has to do something like the
same thing that is it has to have a
model of how the economy works that is a
good model it's that it predicts
outcomes and it it helps us understand
the workings of a modern economy but at
the same time is one which recognizes
the importance of things that people who
are opposed to the neoliberal
prescriptions would uh think so for
example uh if if you think that there is
something questionable about the
exercise of immense powers of one
individual over another
uh if you think that's something which
we should interrogate from a democratic
standpoint is that really okay is it
even okay from the standpoint of Liberty
if that's on your mind well then you
better have an economic theory which
shows that oh yes that kind of power
really is consistent with an equilibrium
in the economy even ideally and you you
can't get rid of it as long as you have
employees and employers and so on so I
think that the challenge facing
economics today is to find a set of
economic theories as economic models
economic Concepts which represent the
economy in a way which we recognize
empirically both experimentally and in
other ways but which also give us space
in which to express and recognize the
kind of moral dilemmas that are there in
the economy for everyone to see but
which economics has been a bit blind to
because of the particular assumptions
about what humans are like and how we
interact one of the blows to the
neoliberal Paradigm was the financial
crisis back in 2008 am I gonna guess
right to say that we can interpret that
as being due in part to this information
and completeness issue yes I mean I
think that what what happened there uh
is clearly a case of taking a market of
financial markets in general uh treating
it like it was an ordinary market for
shirts something in which the standard
model works okay uh and then uh
deregulating it in in such a way that
you're almost certain to have a
speculative uh Bubbles and
um and instability so that was a case of
applying the neoliberal medicine to a a
a a a problem which in which it didn't
work and it was it so obviously it
didn't work and it so obviously caused a
lot of Havoc to people that uh you know
everyone was saying well what wrong and
why didn't you guys get it I mean the
queen went to the London School of
economics and he's and she scolded them
and said how did you guys get it so
wrong and they kind of sheefishly had to
answer and try to explain how they got
it so wrong and I think I think from
there there was just an openness to
thinking well I wonder what was wrong
and if we were wrong about that maybe we
were wrong about some other things
I think there are a couple of other
things which were also building up
um and uh one is growing inequalities
um somehow uh over the since the 80s uh
the U.S economy most of the uh High
income economies have been coming uh
significantly more unequal both in
wealth and in terms of income the US is
is an outstanding example of this a bit
extreme compared to others but um
uh people care about inequality they
care about the suffering that inequality
inflicts on the people who are
um less well-off and I think there's a
sense that well our our apparatus wasn't
really allowing us to ask questions
about that
um a lot of the inequality comes from
the things which we said that didn't
exist like unemployment I mean if Supply
equals demand we couldn't even talk
about one of the problems that people
face which is finding a
a decent job and uh I'm I'm virtually
certain that the um the other thing in
addition to the financial crisis and
inequality uh is is is climate change
yeah climate change is is frightening
everyone
um and you know it's if if we go back in
economics and look at the last time we
had a big change it was the Great
Depression that did it Keynes and then
Paul Samuelson he's a great textbook uh
and um so what that uh what that did is
it you know that that whole
configuration of events we had a big
economic problem that the standard
Paradigm didn't explain very well we had
some new economics that did seem to
explain it pretty well and moreover we
had a set of social movements Trade
union movements in some parts of the
world communist movements which were
challenging the status quo uh and so
there was a sense of urgency that we had
to address these problems uh both
because they were urgent and they were
causing human suffering but also what
was on samuelson's mind was the Cold War
and there was an alternative to
capitalism which was of course communism
which was doing at the time quite well I
had not had a Great Depression like the
capitalist countries that had and so on
uh now so you know when I think about
well where are we in economics today are
are we at a similar moment I mean I
sometimes call it a samuelsonian moment
for Paul Samuelson
I don't know we surely have a set of new
problems that economics is not equipped
to deal with in its in its conventional
form the ones we just mentioned
Financial instability uh climate change
inequality and some others future of
work uh we have a set of theories that
have been uh being constructed not by a
great thinker like Keynes but by
literally hundreds of um uh um
mostly economic theorists and others uh
uh developing this idea of the economy
in which markets don't necessarily clear
people are not necessarily selfish and
the equilibrium is not the uh the only
state the economy will be in and so on
uh I I don't see uh a set of societal
movements pushing for change that would
require us to adopt this kind of new
view of society
if I were a bit more utopian I'd say is
this
in a well-organized society given the
fact we have these new problems and this
new knowledge we should put the two
together and Implement them uh and I
mean that would be a good idea but
obviously uh there are a lot of people
benefiting from the status quo just the
way it is and so you're not going to
implement a whole new set of ways of
understanding things in new sets of
policies and so on uh without organizing
a fairly significant set of social
movements uh in in the U.S and around
the world and so on uh which will be
calling for change uh if that happens uh
then I'm pretty sure uh that we'll want
to adopt the new economics because
otherwise we won't have the tools to fix
the problems
one of the things you've been working on
to try to develop this new economics is
a better model more realistic model the
individual actors right I mean if Adam
Smith says everyone can be
self-interested and things are still
okay nevertheless not everyone is always
completely self-interested so tell us
where how we can try to understand that
better well uh oddly enough we take off
from Adam Smith uh he uh he wrote a book
not as famous as the one in which she
announced the Invisible Hand called the
theory of moral sentiments moral
sentiments to Smith uh in his 18th
century language we're simply caring
about other people uh caring about their
well-being and uh he said you know we
often just care about other people
without expecting anything in return and
uh he also emphasized uh that one of the
things we take very seriously is our own
dignity
um and it's
um
many students will remember from Smith
that he said
um he's talking here about self-interest
he said uh it's not from the benevolence
of the butcher the Baker and the Brewer
that you put your dinner on the table
but it's from their regard for their
self-interest and and in everybody's
text including mine as an undergrad I
underlined that in fact I put an
exclamation point next to it because I
thought that might be on the exam anyway
it was a pretty important idea it's not
their benevolence uh it's their
self-interest and so this then was a
sort of groundwork for thinking of how
the economy works but when I went back
to look at that a couple of years ago I
found something amazing which is the
very next sentence in Smith's book is he
said nobody but a beggar would would
rely on the benevolence of others for
their dinner
so Smith's argument about self-interest
and the market and so on it had nothing
to do with efficiency it didn't really
have much to do with the Invisible Hand
really it had to do with the market as
being in us a way of organizing Society
that's consistent with people being
dignified and having equal dignity uh
well then you looked today I mean that
was Smith's idea I mean the alternative
to the market was a kind of feudal
society in which some people were said
to be naturally Superior to others and
uh capable of ordering them around uh
where you had a tremendous gender
differences in the rights and uh uh and
freedom of people not to mention the
people who were enslaved and so on so
you know the idea of interacting in
markets you know had a great appeal
because you had the right to say no
um now running that forward of course we
have a slightly different view
I mean I I remember thinking and
watching with horror as some um during
the covid epidemic early on there was
women working in a meat packing Factory
in the midwest in the United States and
they were frightened about going to work
as well they should have been sure and
they were ordered to go to work or they
would be fired well uh and of course
there you see an exercise of Power by
the employer placing these women in
grave danger a danger by the way that
the employer himself was not exposed to
because he could easily keep himself
away from crowded circumstances and so
on now just watching that you think oh
there's something wrong here now
uh
um the the idea that people are
self-interested has has a funny history
to it
um uh Smith didn't think it was true
um uh he just said let's see how it
would work if they were if it was true
uh many other people who've tried out
this idea of let's see if we can get
laws and regulations that can't be
foiled by selfish people and therefore
design a constitution for people as if
they were selfish
um uh they've said immediately but
that's not really what people are like
now um A6 uh a predecessor of Smith uh
David Yume he went so far as to say this
um uh uh in designing a constitution we
must assume that everyone is a Nave you
use the old word everyone is a Nave and
has only their interests at heart and
then he went on to say by his avarice we
shall rule him for the greater good good
so the idea of harnessing the avarice of
the uh the selfish person is a big idea
in economics now interestingly Hume in
the in the next sentence said it may
seem odd that that a an axiom which is
true for the design of constitution
namely the the Nave idea uh wouldn't be
true if you observe Society so this idea
of Designing a Nave proof Constitution
has a big uh history in economics now uh
it's it's always difficult as a teacher
you know you teach students well this is
what we think and the students think
well do you think I'm like that are you
like that and you know it's a lot of
confusion no we don't think that we're
just assuming that and and so on uh
psychologists have always uh been a bit
dismissive of economists in the score
because psychologists do experiments and
they've been doing experiments you know
since the 50s on this and you know they
found out a lot of stuff uh I mean for
example in the early 70s they found out
that people care a huge amount about
self-determination uh so that for
example I mean this is a wonderful one
if uh if uh if kids are playing and some
are painting pictures and some are doing
other things and whatever then the ones
who paint pictures if you pay them a
dollar for their picture oh Johnny what
a nice picture uh and then in a control
group the ones who painted say oh Johnny
what a nice picture but you don't pay
them anything and then you look and see
what happens later it's extraordinary
even two weeks later the ones who were
paid for their pictures have stopped
painting they're not painting anymore
really yes uh now the interpretation of
that experiment was
kids these are these are actually little
kids they're elementary school kids kids
have a sense of self-determination what
the psychologist said is uh the payment
is what's what they called in their
technical language over justification it
provided another reason why I did it
maybe I just did it for the money oh if
I did it for the money but they're not
paying now well I guess I'll play in the
sandbox instead uh now it wasn't until
the 90s The Economist started doing
experiments and I have to say I think
these experiments that economists did
were actually better than the
psychological experiments they're better
for two reasons one is by the time the
90s came around we all knew Game Theory
so we knew how to design an experiment
which clearly isolated one set of
incentives and supposed to the other and
so on so we were trying to uh use
experimental Behavior to back out from
the experimental Behavior a function
called a utility function the thing
which the individuals Mac maximizing
which would explain that behavior so
that all of our experiments had it you
know our for us the Holy Grail was
reverse engineering what must have been
the thing which was being optimized that
was a pretty good idea and the other one
is we always paid we're always played
for money uh that is you uh basically
those Economist yes I mean you know they
and so we had if we were dividing up the
pi between me and you and I get to do
anything I like with it it wasn't
hypothetical it's actually a hundred
dollars or ten dollars
um uh in some cases much larger sums and
now
um those experiments some of which my
team did a team of which I was a part
around the world uh they were really
remarkable what what we found uh was
that
um in in the experiments that we
conducted the entirely selfish
consistently selfish person was really a
minority very few people acted self in
the way that economists had assumed and
what we had was a bunch of other kinds
of behaviors I mean some people were
kind of unconditional altruists
um and sort of Mother Teresa types other
people were
all DeGeneres with you but if you're not
generous to me I'll be vindictive
towards you there's some kind of really
tough reciprocity
um uh we also found out uh which didn't
surprise us but it's very distressing
that people are very group identity
oriented sure uh and um so we found out
a lot of things that were not in the
economic model and then one of the
things we've been doing for the past 30
years is saying okay well suppose this
field called behavioral economics
suppose that those findings are true how
should economics be different if people
really do care about others not all the
time not when they're shopping but
perhaps when they're interacting with
neighbors and perhaps when they're are
interacting with the people they employ
or with their employer or with their
loved ones radical idea that people
could care about the welfare of others
yes now I mean the problem the problem
is that in doing these experiments is
you know after we do this experiments
we're pretty excited and pretty proud of
ourselves and so we'd go around inside
sometimes lecture in anthropology or
sociology departments and I would
announce this newfound knowledge that I
had that not everybody is entirely
selfish and they would say well tell me
something I didn't know now uh I pushed
back pretty hard on that because
um I do think that the kinds of
experiments we did uh the the design of
them the fact that they were for real
payoffs and so on meant that we did have
a much more solid uh set of findings
about the importance of altruism and
importance of reciprocity and the
importance of another thing that comes
through in the experiments people really
are fair-minded uh they they not only
don't like it when they're treated
unfairly they don't even like it when
they are advantaged from being from
unfair treatment and so I think that's
made a difference
um but
um I was never very good at designing
experiments I mean I I I had ideas about
what we'd like to find out but the
actual design of a good experiment is uh
it's a it's a real skill uh and I of
course participated with the team in
doing this uh but I pretty quickly moved
on because my interest in sociobiology
led me to ask an obvious question which
is how could a species ever evolve uh
with a substantial fraction of its
members being altruistic and this wasn't
just a hypothetical question that came
to me uh a reaction that I had when
lecturing was often from economists and
from biologists well look I don't know
about your experiments but what I do
know is that natural selection cannot
produce an altruistic species and the
reason for that is pretty obvious
altruism is defined as benefiting
somebody else at a cost to yourself now
uh in a population genetics model the
benefits and costs are Fitness so if I'm
contributing to the fitness of some
other at a fitness cost to myself then
my share of the population an altruistic
type will fall and the non-altruists
will grow that reasoning is correct by
the way there's nothing wrong with that
reasoning and it's a pretty good
definition
so
I went to work on uh what was this a
substantially new project which is well
I was pretty convinced that we were
altruistic it might not be that we're
genetically altruistic that we're
altruistic for cultural reasons but it's
pretty surprising to find it so
Universal because we had done
experiments with hunter-gatherers in the
Amazon with herders in Mongolia with
farmers in India with truck drivers in
America and so on not just students or
you know can't populations like you have
access to uh so uh a lot of what I've
been of what I worked on uh was uh
studying models by to ask the question
could humans possibly have become
altruistic uh from a genetic standpoint
that is genetically predisposed towards
helping others
um and uh that comes down that's an
empirical question uh it it surely could
have been the case I mean here's here's
a here's a narrative about how it could
have happened
um it's true that in any group The
altruists would be doing poorly because
they'd be helping others and not getting
help
but a group that was composed mostly of
altruist would do very well as a group
for example in competition with another
group if the other group had no
altruists I mean uh it doesn't have to
be a matter of warfare but uh suppose
the two groups came into conflict well
the altruistic group would all be
willing to help each other they'd all
volunteer for military service or to go
into combat the non-altruists will all
be you know after uh you know after UL
funds uh and um then there would uh and
so all you have to have is a past a
period of time in our past in which
small groups competed for resources
either during environmental crises or uh
because of uh just doing military
competition
um uh and
um then that could be an environment in
which if groups were different enough
genetically then and if the ones with
altruist one and the ones that not
Alters Lost That Could more than offset
the fact that within every group The
altruists would always be losing a
little bit and so I developed a set of
mathematical models and I did actually I
learned population genetics and I did
some research on the genetics of
hunter-gatherer groups as a way of
trying to figure out what we might have
been like in the pleistocene in the
prior to the uh change in temperature
about 11 000 years ago in climate and uh
similar to my surprise I found that
humans possibly well certainly unusually
possibly uniquely as a species
were capable of constructing
institutions and living in a situation
because of our Technologies and so on
such that this process called group
selection could actually be a very
powerful evolutionary force and so we
end up I think with uh with now we have
strong experimental evidence that we are
generous in many circumstances we have
models and data which suggest that that
might even be a uh a genetic
predisposition and of course we know
there are many cultural reasons why we
would be taught to be that way so I
think you know
um that's my corner of some of the
research that I've done about the
question of what human beings are like
and you know if you're thinking of a new
economic Paradigm you have to come down
on on that somehow you can't say we're
selfish and really smart I mean if you
know the bumper sticker for my Paradigm
is people are a lot dumber and nicer
than economists think
I guess we'll take that dumber and nicer
maybe that's a good trade-off but uh
obviously you're wading into treacherous
Waters here because biologists have
debated for a long time over whether
what levels of selection there are right
I mean there's Hamilton's principle I'm
willing to do altruistic things for my
close relatives not for my far relatives
but the idea of group selection where
I'm just in a group and I'm willing to
sacrifice for them even though maybe
they don't share so much of my DNA uh do
you think that this economic viewpoint
on it has strengthened the case for that
even in biology
well I think that it strengthened the
case for group selection properly
modeled uh in the Hamilton way that is
um I think Hamilton's way of modeling
individual based selection with
individuals competing for Fitness is the
right way to model any evolutionary
process uh I mean we can improve on what
Hamilton said and wrote uh
um I think that um
group selection was in the doghouse for
a long time among biologists uh for two
reasons one is they didn't think it was
empirically likely that genetic
differences between groups would be
large enough so that one group winning
and the other one losing would make
enough of a difference to offset the
within group
erosion of the uh of the altruists but
there was another reason uh which is
that
um
uh the idea of uh group selection seemed
to be that people were doing things for
the group and it was the groups that
were being selected and not the people
the group selections are rather
unfortunate term because it looks like
the unit of selection is a group uh now
there are models in which you can have
the unit of selection being in group and
they're not nonsensical but uh but some
of the ideas about group selection and
the groups being selected didn't make a
lot of sense formally and mathematically
so they were both mathematical and
empirical reasons ultimately it's
individuals who are reproducing that's
right uh and um and you know people like
to express that in terms of the genes
reproducing but it's the individuals who
bear the genes and so I'm fine with an
entirely individual based model of the
evolutionary process for human behaviors
uh and uh and that's what I and now many
other people have shown that is as long
as the groups are different enough
genetically
then the process works now what does
that mean well if they're different
enough genetically it means I am
actually more closely related to the
people in my group than I am to a
randomly selected member of the
population if that if that were not true
group selection couldn't work so the
connection to Kin selection is that this
is kin selection writ large it could be
people who are quite distantly related
to you but all it takes is that the
groups are more like Ken than the random
population I think the you know again in
in my mind kin selection got a bad name
because it was a good theory Hamilton's
Theory but people interpreted it to mean
that our generosity extends only as far
as our immediate family
and of course we observe that's not true
it's not our just our sisters and
brothers and parents and kids uh and uh
so I think that actually I think the
biology of the evolution of human
behavior has really made huge advances
and it's interesting now that uh for
example group selection has become a
much more widely accepted idea partly
because E.O Wilson endorsed the idea of
group selection before his uh his death
um and his his status of course helps a
lot I guess when we talk about Game
Theory and its use in in these analyzes
well what I have in mind which is
completely unaffected by actual
knowledge of what is going on is
something like you know I have a
population of a lot of people they
interact pairwise with other people and
they all have strategies and there's
payoffs for their strategies and maybe
their mixed strategies rather than pure
strategies and I could run some giant
simulation and find uh equilibrium
distribution of strategies is that
anywhere close to what you actually do
that's right I mean I I would add
there's a there's a missing part of that
which is how does the population
fraction of strategies change uh and all
you have to add to that is the idea that
uh people who are
um that is strategies that on average
have higher payoffs are going to grow
yeah now there could be the higher
payoffs there could mean uh um greater
Fitness if it was a genetic model but it
could also be a cultural model in which
people who do better uh get copied uh
just culturally so uh non-smokers
actually seem to be pretty happy and
they live longer maybe they're more
likely to marry more uh maybe
non-smokers kids are more likely to copy
their non-smoking than his smokers kid
would copy their smoking and so on so
yeah I mean you can take this idea of
what's called in mathematics a
replicator equation or replicator
dynamic and then say it's payoff
monotonic all that means is that the
fraction of that strategy will go up if
it's above average and go down if it's
below average and that's just a standard
formalization of natural selection with
Fitness
and all you do is change it to any kind
of copying uh so then you have a
cultural model and a biological model
the math is the same at the most
abstract level but then obviously if
it's a cultural model then you might
want to amend it a little bit you might
say well payoffs are one thing but I'd
like to take account of the fact that
people also tend to copy things which
are most common in our population so
fine then it's very easy to amend the
cultural Fitness equation to include two
weighted terms one is the payoffs and
the other is how uh how many others in
the population there are and once you
realize that you do you have a machine
there it's just a mathematical
expression that you can add stuff to
that's pretty intuitive and you know and
we know for each of those things there's
probably some truth to it you copy
people who are doing well you copy uh
the majority uh you know we've you know
so that's basically the standard the the
way the standard models work and uh you
know there there's some big puzzles you
know because they're they're things that
are that are culturally successful that
are biologically disasters yeah I
mentioned smoking you know people you
know annually convert to smoking and
yeah and people die and uh or consider
cities uh until two centuries ago cities
were a biological disaster and a
cultural success
um I mean the death rates in cities were
higher than in the countryside I did
people kept flooding the cities in the
way we got cities was the cultural
selection process was swamping the
biological one
um and you know so you know we we really
need to see I mean a a good sociobiology
is one which takes the cultural and the
genetic uh or biological um together and
what I said is mathematically that it's
not hard to do we need I mean in as in
many areas we think oh this is very
complicated very Advanced very novel it
isn't any of those things things it's
standard theory that just we need to
know more facts I guess one of the
issues with any system that depends on
Cooperative behavior is that there will
be Free Riders right people who skate by
on the goodness of others and maybe a
slightly depressing implication of what
we're talking about here is sure there
will be some fraction of Free Riders but
as long as there's not too many of them
the group as a whole will do okay
that well that's certainly right uh and
the last thing you said is true uh as
long as they're not too many of them uh
now it's interesting to see how
societies really deal with Free Riders
um and
um uh let's go back in history and
pre-history and think about maybe a
hundred thousand years in which
biologically modern humans were
primarily foragers that is mobile
hunter-gatherers uh we have very good
reason to think that uh they shared food
that's in part because they acquired
food in very large packages that is
large game they didn't have a fridge so
obviously they're gonna share the food
they rarely got uh and they got their
prey I mean I've actually hunted with
hunter-gatherers and the group I was
hunting with the the hit rate the
likelihood of getting something was
extraordinarily small maybe once a month
uh so you've you've got to share uh now
in those societies of course there's
somebody's says well okay I'll share at
the pot but I won't go hunting well uh
the free rider problem must have been
there and they found ways of dealing
with it what we know from modern
ethnographic studies is simple things
like for example you eat in public no
you eat in public so everybody knows hey
you know who's who's getting the stuff
from the bottom and the other thing is
again from modern ethnographic studies
uh the the free writers are not treated
well they're joked about they're
ridiculed and eventually if they insist
they're actually physically punished so
um now what can we learn from that today
well let's think about public goods uh
or
um any kind of common thing which we
have
we've studied in experiments how do
people contribute to these things and
they're always free writers so in a
what's called a standard public goods
game which that's just a prisoner's
dilemma with a lot of people so it's an
end person prisoner's dilemma in which
uh it's in everybody's selfish interest
to not contribute but it's in the
interests of everyone if everyone
contributes
um now in those games typically if you
play them consecutively you know over
many periods people start off hoping for
the best they contribute a fair amount
to the public good but then they notice
that other people aren't contributing uh
and then they so they and they think
well uh the only way I have to do to
avoid being a sucker is all I won't
contribute
um now if you stop the game after say 10
Rounds
and you say okay from now on you're all
going to see uh the contributions of the
other members not by name of course but
just by some symbol and you can take
some of your payoffs that you've already
won uh and for a cost you can actually
punish uh the people who are you can
punish anybody we don't say they who
they would punish and we would never use
the word punish we'd just say you can
pay you can you can pay one Euro to
reduce the payoffs of this of anybody
else by two Euros or something like that
uh and um and what happens is
extraordinary
they punish like crazy uh and uh so in
the second set of 10 Rounds uh the uh
the amount contributed which had gone
down almost to zero goes up much much
higher up to 80 or something and by the
by the end of the game uh almost
everyone is contributing nobody's
punishing uh and um so now let's think
about that I mean there's a lot to
unpack here
the most obvious thing is this the
second game has a public goods game
contributing to the public good but then
it has punishing but punishing is also a
public good because if I punish this guy
everyone benefits if he or she shapes up
so in the first public goods game it
collapsed and they all end up doing
nothing but in the second public goods
game the combination of the What's
called the public goods game and the
punishment game everybody punishes a lot
until it's not necessary
well that's interesting
um are we uh genetically or culturally
uh predisposed to be really irritated at
free writers uh if given the opportunity
we're willing to actually pay out of our
pocket so as to punish them well it
turns out that we are
um and um so the so now we can think
about oh in other experiments by the way
it uh we've found out that even if the
target of the punishment won't even know
about the punishment until after the
game is over people want to punish now
that's crazy because they can't possibly
affect their behavior it makes them feel
good they just want to punish the free
writers so we know a lot about uh the
punishing of free writers uh but it's
typically done better if it's done by
peers who share your situation and for
whom it seems like an altruistic act so
imposing punishments from the top often
backfires uh you know we found out for
example that during the covet epidemic
uh mandating vaccines incurred a very
hostile response whereas your neighbors
saying you know I really feel a lot a
lot better if you go and get vaccinated
was more effective uh now uh so when we
think about this uh what I think is that
we're missing out in terms of our
resources for making Society better
typically we have two tools we go with
the state and we have markets uh and uh
then the state basically has a set of
regulations and laws uh which it
implements uh based on elections if
you're in a Democratic Society those are
obeyed because of some notion of
obedience to the state or maybe fear of
the of punishment the markets have their
own ways of implementing things through
buying and selling stuff and uh those
things the the buying and selling is
motivated by self-interest or some
combination of self-interest and other
preferences
um and uh but it strikes me that if we
look at what works in society we're
missing another dimension I mean the the
debates that we have are really imagine
a line running from State over on the
left to Market over on the right and
then where there's a tug of war between
the Democrats are trying to pull it over
towards the state and Republicans are
trying to pull it over towards the
market or at least that's the way
Republicans used to be uh and
um now uh when I say there's something
missing uh I guess the expression I
would use is community or civil society
that is that's the place where people
gossip about each other where they
appoint the finger that is you have an
opinion of your neighbors and you
express it uh that's the place where you
know how do communities work well they
work through people really caring about
each other often in negative ways for
example I mean a lot of our communities
have to do was wanting to live in a
relatively homogeneous place and for
example having a racist or homophobic
attitude towards other people so I don't
put Community here forward as a
normative ideal any more than I see the
state and the market as a normative
ideal it's just an arena in which our
moral ideas and our very high level
information because we're neighbors can
be brought to bear so as to control
things like free writing and you know
perhaps make possible a a more effective
uh company or more effective Cooperative
Enterprise of some kind because you have
a group of people who actually we know
what each other are doing and we praise
each other and we occasionally sort of
deride each other if we're not doing a
good job that's how a well-functioning
economy has to work and that's
increasingly the case today because you
know if you think of the economy at the
time of Adam Smith or for that matter of
Karl Marx you know producing steel and
textiles and grain and so on those were
mostly things which you can you can
measure you know how much grain was
produced and you can tell pretty much
how much uh textiles this person made
and so on and and you can sell this
stuff
um the stuff can be packaged so it's
sometimes why am I contrasting this to
today well look at the work of today a
lot of work today is just like what
we're doing it's people talking uh we're
expressing ideas we're entertaining
people we're doing cultural uh
production but uh much more than that we
work in restaurants uh we're waiting on
table uh we that we're engaged in the
care of the old and the young the
teaching of people uh that is the vast
majority of people in the modern economy
are doing the things I just mentioned in
the United States one in seven Works in
manufacturing mining uh and things which
have smokestacks and you would think of
as being on the cover of your economics
textbook so most of the things we're
doing are really hard to measure and
what it means that in most of what we're
doing contracts don't really work very
well and for the same reasoning neither
do government Fiats because for the same
reason that you can't contract from my
work effort the government can't force
me to work either and the government
can't force me to be a good citizen and
they can't force me to be tolerant of my
gay neighbor or of uh my Republican uh
neighbor uh and so on so it's having a
decent Society requires that we mobilize
all those things we've learned about
free writing uh and the to bring to bear
the kinds of moral pressures that people
have and to find a way also to minimize
the repugnant moral pressures that often
go along with the word Community let me
just ask one question which is sort of
looming in the background here we're in
a situation in the world where we have
these kinds of challenges that are
larger in scale maybe than we've used
used to be thinking of either global
scale things or long-time Horizons
whether it's climate change or future
pandemics
nothing that I can think of in the
sociobiology or or even our local
cultural norms equips us to deal with
those kinds of things do you have either
more uh prescriptive things to say or
just some room for optimism there
yes I do that may surprise you and it'll
surprise you even more the analogy that
I'm going to use as the basis of my
optimism
I think we can learn from nationalism
nationalists okay that we should be
optimistic about the possibility of a
more Global mentality
let's go back and think about what
nationalism did now by the way to start
with I hate nationalism I I think it
leads us to be narrow-minded to hate
Outsiders and so on but I want to talk
about the constructive role that
nationalism had I'll take the case of
Italy that I know quite well uh the
Italian language has existed for a very
long period of time and in that sense
Italians have existed but Italy didn't
exist the people from Naples didn't
really talk to or care about the people
from Milan uh and the the the people
from Milan were quite disparaging about
the people from the South and even
little communities actually spoke
somewhat different dialects and so on uh
there was no sense in the world that a
person that a Neapolitan would be
willing to risk their life on behalf of
a person from Valencia or a distant
place like that what nationalism in
Italy and France and the United States
did is it created a sense of
togetherness of an us that is really
remarkable Now France and Italy is not
so remarkable really uh what about the
United States uh the US of Americans
just take a picture look at it uh look
at the people who are willing to
essentially go to bat for each other uh
there are grandparents uh maybe spoke
different languages we're in different
countries and so on nonetheless that has
happened now uh now what do I learn from
that well one thing I learned is that
kind of Us and Them sentiment is the
basis of many wars and many Horrors that
have imposed on Humanity but it also
means that as a cultural animal human
beings are capable of overcoming uh the
past differences the old Antiquated uses
and thems for a larger us now whether or
not it's I mean and I think it's
possible for us to uh extend that to
others in other countries now whether
it's possible that we do that soon
enough uh to uh
um to essentially minimize the risk of
warfare and also economic disasters in
parts of the world uh that's it's hard
to say but I think we have that capacity
I worry more about our capacity to feel
the same way about future Generations
um that's um because uh of course what
we say is well can't you imagine your
grandchildren your great-grandchildren
but yes but we're talking about a very
long future when we talk about climate
change and the need to preserve a
livable planet
um but I um I think I mean there's
generally is good news in the sense that
um if you go back to where economics was
30 40 years ago we were still back in
the dark old days of homo economics
economic man the one who was really
smart and selfish and uh you know I
don't think anyone believes that anymore
not even economists don't believe it and
I even think among biologists there is
an interest uh in the conditions under
which a species may become even
genetically predisposed to care now um
if we can care about someone in
Bangladesh or someone in Norway distant
Place uh uh of course we can also I care
about somebody who may live 200 years
from now uh but I think it's a little
harder to imagine that and I think we're
going to have to work very hard to
achieve that
but being Dumber but nicer is at least
one step in the right direction I I have
to agree it sounds good to me so sambles
thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast okay
[Music]
mama